yes it is officially hot girl summer and
we are ready for it we want to get back
to some
normalcy and erica doesn't that mean we
should treat ourselves a little bit
after the year that we have yes yes yes
so we have teamed up
with lifestyle experts erica vitrini and
racketon
to show us how to indulge while also
earning some big rewards right
that's right so definitely indulge in
some shopping but make sure you shop
smart with racket and on all of your
favorite brands
right now it's big give week where you
get 15 cash back on hundreds of stores
so what are some of the tips or products
that you recommend to people
schedule uninterrupted me time go
outdoors move your body
and make sure you look cute while you do
it i just picked up these really
adorable pair of reebok sneakers they
are so cute and speaking of looking
cute going back to taking care of your
skin and investing in skincare that
works
i picked up this estee lauder eye cream
that i cannot live without and actually
scored both of these on racketon
erica i love this i can get some me time
and
get a little cash back doing it all this
is boss lady energy